- Des documents longtemps
convoités. Plus de 6000 pages
de déclarationi i i i i i i i i,
minent une fois de plus
l'intégrité de Donald Trump.
VALÉRIE BEAUDOIN, chercheuse,
Chaire R
- On apprend que Donald Trump
avaient des comptes
à l'étranger. On apprend qu'il a
des années où il n'a pas payé
déficitaires.- Avec une fortunee
à plus de 3 milliards de dollars
l'ancien président n'a rien
versé au trésor américain
en 2020.
Contrairement à ce qu'il
prétendait en campagne,
il n'a déboursé qu'un million
des trois premières années
de sa présidence.
Dorurururump prévient
de la difficulté d'analyser
ces informations fiscales
quququququququququququququququqr
de payer des impôts. 2 2 2 2016,
son entreprise d'aviation
DT Endeavor a déclaré
Curieuse coïncidence :
les dépenses se sont élevées
à 680 886 $, précisément.
n'a donc pas payé d'impôts.
- Donc, on est un peu
on regarde les revenus de Donald
Trump, le paiement à l'impôt.
quand ça allait très, très mal.
- L'étoile de l'homme d'affaires
la Trump Organization a été
reconnue coupable de fraudes
fait pour éviter de rendre
publiques ses relevés,
un tradi
soumis tous les présidents
depuis Richard Nixon.
Au terme d'un long bras de fer,s
jours avant de céderlalalalala s
aux Républicains.
- Je pense que pour lesifififife
de faire mal à Donald Trump.
Peu importe la façon de le
faire. Oui, on veut quand même
de la transparence, oui on dit
depuis les années 70, depuis
Richard Nixon, de donner ses
rapports d'impôt, mais au-delà
de ça, on se dit : "Est-ce qu'il
a fait quelque chose
- Une ultime tentative pour
éloigner Trump de la proch
présidentielle.
Ici Jean-Philippe Hughes,
Radio-Canada, Mon